private sector thinks military is all
command and control right do this do as
I tell you take an order and so they
think that being a strong leader because
they've seen too many movies is barking
orders and telling people what to do now
you know as well as I do that that that
that is a part of leadership um where
you I'm going to tell you a task without
any context and you're going to do it
but that is reserved for moments of
chaos and when there is N Chaos you're
spending time building trust you're
spending time offering context you're
spending time building the spr of core
so that when you are in a chaotic
situation you absolutely can bark orders
and scream and yell because I don't have
time for feedback and I don't have time
to give you context and they will follow
the orders with high motivation because
they trust they trust that you would not
give them an order that would needlessly
put them at Danger even though they
understand that you'll sometimes make
mistakes and so I think in business in
private sector we need to learn to
adjust as well which is command and
control works fine in short periods of
time and moments of chaos but it cannot
be nobody has the energy to endure that
on a daily basis